You have to see this video.
This is a great side story as Donald Trump
has been melting down on Twitter as his children
and Rudy Giuliani have been melting down at
press conferences.
Donald Trump's spiritual advisor, Paula White,
led a prayer service to, I guess, fight off
the demons that might prevent Donald Trump
from winning.
I am going to issue a warning I would get
if you're watching with kids today, get the
kids out of the room.
If you're listening with kids, maybe put some
put some headphones in.
This is extremely disturbing.
It will contain graphic video indicative of
severe, untreated, maybe even undiagnosed
mental illness.
Here is, Paula, quite striking and striking
and striking down, I guess, demons so that
Trump will get reelected.
She then starts speaking in tongues, strike
and strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike until you have victory for every
enemy that is aligned against you.
Let there be that we would strike the ground
for you will give us victory.
God, I hear a sound of abundance of rain.
I hear a sound of victory.
I hear a sound of shouting and singing.
I hear a sound of an abundance of rain.
I hear a sound of victory.
I hear a sound a victory.
The Lord says it is done.
For I hear victory, victory, victory, victory
in the corridors of heaven.
In the corridors of heaven.
Victory, victory.
Victory for angels are being released right
now.
Angels are being dispatched right now among
the dead abakar sundiata.
I'm also Catholic to expand the authority
to DDR.
Shut-off for Angels have even dispatched from
Africa right now.
Africa right now from Africa.
Right now they're coming here.
They're coming here in the name of Jesus from
South America.
They're coming here.
They're coming here from Africa, from South
America.
Angelic forces, angelic reinforcement, angelic
reinforcement, angelic reinforcement.
And under attack that the commander rusada
for.
I hear the sound of victory.
Now, obviously, I'm not going to analyze the
specifics of what she's saying, but this is
someone who Donald Trump has given actual
prominent placement at the White House for.
Various religious events, I like how she talks
about dispatched angels from Africa to help
Trump, I hope they're not coming from asshole
countries because they're not going to be
allowed in.
It's going to be trouble.
Then Paula White battles the demonic confederacies
that are trying to steal the election from
Trump.
Also, I don't know if you noticed in the first
clip, if you were watching, there's a guy
who keeps walking back and forth behind Paula
White holding papers are a book.
Who's that guy?
What's he doing?
Just every detail here is hilarious.
We break it, divide every demonic confederacy
against the election, against America, against
who you have declared to be in the White House.
We break it up in the name of Jesus.
We lose confusion into every demonic confederacy
directed right now at this election, directed
specifically at the six states.
We come against people that are working at
high levels right now with demonic confederacies
and secrecy's and demonic plans and networks.
We break it up and we command that to be exposed
right now in the name of Jesus really seems
like somebody might have spiked the holy water
with something fierce there, if you know what
I'm saying.
I think the most logical thing Paula White
said there, what made the most sense from
those two clips is when Paula White said her
Monda aka Hotta Rocka Teda Bokha, Condah Hotta,
that I understood more than everything else
that went on in that clip.
We have to be able to call this mental illness
plain and simple, right?
I mean, in other words, I know that there
are people who will say, David, it's offensive
to say that that's mental illness, because
this is these are this is just religious belief.
How is that not mental illness?
How is that explain to me how it's not mental
illness.
If anybody did that but didn't claim it was
their religion.
If you show up and to a police station and
you say Amanda Hakata rocka Ted Abaca conductor,
you get a 72 hour psych hold because she's
doing it in a church with a mic and a guy
with a Bible behind her, we're supposed to
just act like this is normal, guys.
We can't do it.
And if you're Joe Biden, you should worry
with her doing that.
I don't know that.
I mean, that seems, Pat, what she's doing
seems powerful.
I don't know how Biden can win anything with
that.
Look at the contrast.
OK, she's talking about witchcraft with Amanda
Canata.
And Donald Trump is trying to stop ballots
from being counted.
Rudy Giuliani is filing six lawsuits.
What Joe Biden said yesterday is let's reduce
the temperature.
I believe I have a path to victory, but I
am not declaring victory.
And if I win, I will be the president for
everybody, every state, red and blue, every
American, no matter whether you voted for
me or you voted for Donald Trump or somebody
else, we have never seen a contrast greater
than this in the Obama, McCain, John Kerry,
Bush.
You know, these these were there were some
bad candidates who did some bad things and
advocated for bad policy.
There has never been a contrast, the likes
of which we are seeing right now.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
You can get the bonus show instantly by becoming
a member at Join Pakman Dotcom, new coupon
code, fresh start.
All one word, all lowercase.
You understand it.
Fresh start, because that's what we hope is
coming here.
I'll see you on the bonus show.